[Musik]
oster ruhe haben die kanzlerin und jetzt
hat sie so viel ärger wie vielleicht
noch nie in ihrer amtszeit oster ruhe
erstmal eingeführt dann wenige tage
später wieder abgeräumt gekippt und
dafür hat sie sich heute für die ganze
unsicherheit die sie der verbreitet
hatte bei allen deutschen entschuldigt
und das klipp und klar zu sagen die idee
eines uster und zwar mit bester absicht
entworfen worden
denn wir müssen es unbedingt schaffen
die dritte welle der pandemie zu bremsen
und umzukehren
dennoch war die idee der sogenannten
oster ruhe ein fehler
sie hatte ihre guten gründe war aber in
der kürze der zeit nicht gut genug
umsetzbar
ja mein fehler sagt die kanzlerin klipp
und klar einzig und allein mein fehler
darüber wollen wir jetzt trocken hier am
abend live bei bild die richtigen fragen
an mario voigt thüringens cdu chef béla
anda den früheren regierungssprecher von
gerd schröder johannes vogel fdp und
anna klaus korrespondentin vom spiegel
hier in berlin in allen schönen guten
abend
flowers nehmen sie die entschuldigung
von frau merkel als bürgerin an
es fällt mir schwer
warum also es ist natürlich wirklich die
ultima ratio und die hat sie gezogen
wenn gar nichts mehr geht dann bleibt
eigentlich nur aufzugeben und sich
zumindest entschuldigen das hat anstand
windig und deswegen akzeptiere ich das
auch aber in meinem kopf kreist immer
noch diese eine buchstabe den reiner
haseloff getötet hat und bodo ramelow
erhält dann auch dieses was soll das
alles was machen die ja eigentlich wir
drehen uns im kreis und ein wird
schwindelig und mir als bürgerin genauso
wie als korrespondentin heran da an der
klaus hat gerade das ist die ultima
ratio wenn der regierungschef sich in
einer solchen form entschuldigt ist das
ein zeichen von stärke heute gewesen
oder zeichen von schwäche
es wird ja von den verschiedenen
journalisten von vielen gewertet als
zeichen der stärke und der jubel darüber
war eine solche einsicht dass man auch
mal den weg gehen muss
und erklären muss meiner falsch gelegen
aber ich meine intention das absolute
eingeständnis des scheiterns denn so
etwas kommt ja nicht über nacht oder nur
in der nacht oder es gibt ja klare
erwägungen wie hat angela merkel auch
immer im zuge ihrer politischen
entscheidungsfindung zur corona krise
erklärt nämlich dass die inzidenz werte
steigen und wir stärken natürlich
weiterhin um 15 20 30 prozent jeden tag
im vergleich zur vorwoche
das war kein argument das hat sie auf
einmal ausgeben
ich bin es sie haben es erwähnt ja das
basta gewöhnt dass ich mir heute
gewünscht und nicht ein
ich war auf dem falschen dampfer denen
das war sie ja nie das war ein
geständnis ihres scheiterns und ich
glaube dass das auch eine absolute
erosion ihrer noch vorhanden macht
bedeuten wird die machtverhältnisse
werden sich anders verlagern beim
heutigen tage an ist das so erfolgt sie
kennen die cdu von allen die hier jetzt
virtuell mit am tisch sitzen dann am
besten also ist das so in der cdu
absolute erosion der macht da bleibt
kein stein auf dem anderen
die zeit merkel ist mit dem heutigen tag
quasi vorbei wenn ich die worte von béla
anda richtig interpretieren ich glaube
dass angela merkel ein zeichen der
stärke gesendet hat und dass das vor
allen dingen ein neues kraft tanken war
weil sie hat nämlich vertrauen bei den
bürgern zurückgeholt wofür kein anderer
der mps die alle mit zugestimmt haben
von der csu bis zur linken die kraft
hatten und sie hat die verantwortung für
etwas übernommen was kollektiv
entschieden wurde
wer jetzt sich der intellekt der zeigt
einfach dass ihm die kraft fehlt
tatsächlich ein eigenes land zu regieren
und angela merkel hat für alle zentral
gesagt so machen wir es nicht und ich
finde das ein zeichen der stärke
sie hat vertrauen zurückgewonnen sagte
vogt johannes vogel fdp
sie haben hingegen heute in der fdp
zumindest wolfgang kubicki hat das
gemacht gefordert die vertrauensfrage zu
stellen das spricht ja nicht dafür dass
sie das so sehen wie er folgt dass sie
mit dem heutigen tag vertrauen gewonnen
hat wieder bei den deutschen christian
linder formuliert es wäre ratsam das
bezog sich ja darauf was man aus der
die eu fraktion gehört also da hat man
schon hier auf den fluren sehr deutlich
sehr viel unmut auch sehr kritische
worte gegen berg kanzlerin würde und
dass wir als opposition in der sache
kritisieren das ist unser job auch in
der pandemie das macht die demokratie
stärker aber ihre eigenen truppen muss
ich schon hinter sich haben und da
konnte man zweifeln denn jetzt natürlich
die nähe also heute im laufe des tages
sondern soweit im bundestag aufnahm
die kolleginnen und kollegen reden hörte
wir werden jetzt natürlich die nächsten
tage sehen wie es weitergeht ich finde
andere fragen aber spannender da nicht
was daraus jetzt voll
was machen wir das machen wir doch herr
vogel aber wenn sie sagen sie wollen mir
ist es ja gerade bundestags
sitzungswoche das heißt man redet noch
mehr miteinander unter den abgeordneten
als sonst es ist haushaltswoche auch
noch zu dem morgen gibt's eine
regierungserklärung also da ist richtig
was los im bundestag heute in dieser
woche was hören sie denn da was sie
spekulieren lässt dass sie gerade sagen
da mal gucken was da diese woche noch
passiert
das habe ich gar nicht dass das so
passiert man hörte aber bis geht also
man hätte er ja extrem kritische stimmen
aus der fraktionssitzung der cdu also
auch bei ihnen bei bild und in anderen
medien wirklich auch zitate in einer
schärfe die ich so noch nicht
wahrgenommen man später einfach der
entrüstung der kollegen geben auch der
koalitionsfraktionen und die muss sie
hinter sich haben bisher ihre mehrheit
im parlament
und sie hat jetzt den kurs korrigiert an
einer stelle wo sich der unmut entlud
und ob das jetzt reicht wird man sehen
müssen jetzt sparen hat ja am anfang der
partie niemals gesagt wir werden uns
viel verzeichnen müssen
und ich finde fehlerkultur dazu gehört
eben auch dass man erst mal fehler
einräumen das hätte ich mir ehrlich
gesagt an anderen stellen stärker
gewinnen zum beispiel im fall auf dass
das in viehställen verbockt worden ist
sie hat das jetzt hier gewählt ich
glaube dass da veranda warst der eben
sagte die oder die kollegin vom spiegel
dieses register kann man natürlich nicht
unendlich oft sie das heißt die
spannende frage ist ja ändert sich
erstmals an der regierungs methodik
ändert sich was der mtk methodik denn
mein distel des gestern ist nicht eine
falsche oder vorgestern sind die falsche
entscheidung getroffen worden sondern da
ist auch eine regierungs methodik an
ihre grenzen gestoßen und das ist
doch die frage die wir uns stellen
müssen herr under trotzdem noch mal ganz
kurz um dann haken dran machen zu können
sie habe mehr erfahrung mit
vertrauensfrage würden sie anstelle von
angela merkel im moment die
vertrauensfrage stellen im bundestag
nein denn dazu gibt es keinen anlass sie
würde die mehrheit bekommen egal die
wieder einzelne auch aus ihren
koalitionsreihen toben oder hinterm
rücken hier was sagen oder kritik äußern
das ist das ist dann tatsächlich etwas
das muss eine oppositionspartei fordern
wie es die fdp gemacht hat aber dass nur
die nichts ändern aber nur einsatz wo
wir sind ja heute aufgewacht mit er
spricht denn die ministerpräsidenten an
mit dem cdu-ministerpräsidenten armin
laschet er sagte
so können wir nicht weitermachen wir
sind aufgewacht heute morgen mit einem
haus seehofer sagte ich war überhaupt
nicht informiert dass die gotteshäuser
nicht offen sein sollen es dann das ist
ja ne sauerei ein bisschen freier
übersetzt das geht so nicht also hier
ist der innenminister auf der einen
seite csu mann
und dann gibt es ja noch den
csu-vorsitzenden dem bayerischen
ministerpräsident und vielleicht
kanzlerkandidaten spielt der neben
angela merkel saß um drei uhr nachts als
team der vernunft bettina vorsicht und
erklärt hat uns allen bundesbürgern
millionen am nächsten morgen auch noch
mal warum diese maßnahmen sinnvoll sind
wie der sich jetzt vor kommt ja das
würde ich gern auch mal wissen was sein
wahrscheinlich so wie der vizekanzler
der diese entscheidung maßgeblich mit
vorangetrieben hat nämlich stolz von
ihrer partei und ich aber hat das
problem
ich möchte gern mal sagen weil das finde
ich hier wirklich anmaßend ich bin hier
nicht in einer rolle von ein
spd-vertreter oder von der partei ist
wirklich nicht meine rolle ich war
regierungssprecher von gerhard schröder
das ist jetzt mittlerweile 15 jahre er
sei aus dem amt gegangen
ich bin unabhängig bin auch mir selbst
eine meinung zu bilden unabhängig von
irgendwann genauso sind dass ich mich
auch gerne und genauso wie heran
genau so sind sie heute abend heran da
auch eingeladen trotzdem der hinweis
alle an herrn scholz ist ja nicht ganz
falsch der da mit im boot saß als die
entscheidung gefallen ist ja letztlich
in dieser
sitzungsunterbrechung sechs stunden
sitzungsunterbrechung im vierer kreis
aber er sucht um das was so bela anda
gerade gesagt hat aufzunehmen können sie
das aufklären was ist denn da eigentlich
los bei ihnen zwischen cdu und csu aber
auch innerhalb der cdu so dass man
entscheidungen trifft anschließend
wieder zurück nimmt der eine dem anderen
den rücken fällt das nicht akzeptiert
und so weiter was ist da los
ich glaube die leute sind einfach
aufgebracht
das gilt für politiker wie für die
bürger und die menschen waren enttäuscht
von 14 uhr bis 3 uhr wurde gesessen und
am ende ist eine oster herausgekommen
die an der lebenswirklichkeit der leute
vorbei gegangen ist gründonnerstag die
geschäfte zu machen
das bedeutet doch massive
wirtschaftliche verluste ist vollkommen
lebensfern ich hoffe meine familie ein
ich weiß dass wenn wir nur den samstag
gehabt hätten hätten wir einen hotspot
an den supermarktkassen produziert und
die inkonsistenzen und die
schwierigkeiten in den regeln das regt
die leute auch momentan haben wir so
eine art fackelumzug auf der tankstelle
aber das geht nicht sortiert zu und wenn
wir nicht aufpassen dass wir das jetzt
einfach mal sauber abtragen in klaren
plan formulieren nachdem tina prinzip
vorgehen testen impfen nachverfolgung
und abstandsregeln wenn wir das
hinkriegen dann glaube ich haben wir
auch das vertrauen zurück und das was
angela merkel gemacht hat
stellvertretend für alle leute die in
der mpk sitzen
er hat gesagt okay ich nehme das auf
mich das ein zeichen von führungsstärke
sich auch zu korrigieren aber sie hat
auch gesagt wir müssen gemeinsam diesen
weg daher ausformulieren und das ist der
erwartungswert in den burgern diesem
land haben ja ist die frage ob die alle
noch das vertrauen haben dass sie
wirklich sagen mensch toll jetzt mein
fehler eingestanden zu haben ab jetzt
läuft es bestimmt besser an der klaus
sie sind absolute söder experten söder
biografien nämlich jetzt saß der ja bei
allen entscheidungen mit einem tisch
genauso wie armin laschet kann das
überhaupt sein dass es der alleinige
fehler von angela merkel ist so wie
sieht es heute formuliert das hat mich
heute ihre tiere dann da saß ja also
ganz genau so auch der vizekanzler olaf
scholz mit aber eben auch die ganze zeit
zum beispiel markus söder nämlich
bekannt dass er die ganze zeit gesagt
hat also oster ruhe
das will ich nicht ja da haben sie
absolut recht also das hat er nicht und
er hat auch heute im bayerischen landtag
mit den kopf hingehalten
wenn man das so sagen kann also er hat
ist jedenfalls angela merkel einmal mehr
bei gesprungen und hat gesagt es ist
auch meine schuld mehr culpa aber ich
denke er wird insgeheim schon auch froh
sein dass angela merkel davor angebracht
ist und jetzt das das das opferlamm
spielt weil die strategie dahinter ist
ja eigentlich für die union total klug
angela merkel tritt im september sowieso
nicht mehr an als bundeskanzlerin
sie wird ja also nicht wiedergewählt
oder überhaupt gewählt
deswegen kann sie ja jetzt alle schuld
auf sich nehmen und dann sozusagen mit
ins politische grab runterschlucken und
ihr ganzes kabinett das scheitern gleich
mit und dann können eben die jungen fünf
jungen ja das sind sie ja auch nicht
laschet und so da aber sie können
jedenfalls so tun als wären sie die neue
csu und sich so generieren als
innerparteiliche opposition aber die
waren heute glaube ich auch alle
überrascht und immerhin so da war so
ehrlich zu sagen okay merkel ist nicht
alleine schuld aber herr vogt ja es ist
sehen sie das auch so ist es also gar
nicht die alleinige schuld von angela
merkel sondern im grunde von allen die
das damit beschlossen haben in der runde
zumindest in der kleinen runde ja nicht
nur die kleinen sondern auch die großen
ich habe heute von einem
ministerpräsidenten dass er auch drei
uhr morgens bei so zentralen
entscheidungen noch fit genug ist alle
herren sinne zu sein und deswegen kann
ich nur sagen das haben alle
unterschiede politischer couleur mit
entschieden aber jetzt sind eine
führungsverantwortung reklamiert und hat
gesagt ich gestehe an den fehler ein
weil auch viele rückmeldungen aus von
den bürgern aus der wirtschaft und
sozialbereich gekommen sind und ich
finde das macht sehr viel stärker und
schauen sich darum in belgien in
frankreich der lok tor und wird doch
gerade gefahren in der anderen ländern
aber wie in deutschland tun gut daran
dass wir eben nicht diese grundfrage
auch oder zu permanent stellen uns die
frage stellen wie lernen wir mit dem
virus zu leben und welche möglichkeiten
und systeme gibt es um das ja nur die
bürger bei
die bürger erwarten natürlich antworten
und genau die antworten gibt es nicht
beziehungsweise wenn sie antworten gibt
dann sind die plötzlich 48 stunden
wieder ganz an
das heran was geht ihnen das wenn sie
jetzt auf die cdu blicken also angela
merkel übernimmt die verantwortung dafür
sagt ich bin ganz alleine schuld an dem
ganzen desaster wird das so ankommen und
wird man dann anschließend sagen ja also
der laschet hat eine weiße weste der
söder hat eine weiße weste die regieren
da strikt durch die krise durch
es gibt da zwei verschiedene strömungen
die wir beachten müssen das erste ist
die das was die menschen glaube ich
denken die das konsumieren diese
nachrichten und ich glaube schon dass
der respekt ist vor der entscheidung von
angela merkel nach dem wort bedient auch
sich sowie hat das gesagt hat die nimmt
die verantwortung auf sich aber die
politische das politische berlin wenn
nichts über nennen will
das zieht daraus auch schlüssel dass
angela merkel man will zuhören oder auch
nicht nur seit heute definitiv eine
leiter sieht sie sagen eine lame duck
ist und die macht wird sich verschieben
in zu armin laschet zu dem cdu
vorsitzenden und vielleicht auch markus
söder aber auf jeden fall ist klar dass
eine entscheidung die nicht durchgesetzt
wird wenn sie denn in kleiner runde
getroffen wird
auch die erosion der macht bedeutet wie
angela merkel vom heutigen tage an
herr vogel sie haben ja auch eine
zeitlang mal mitregieren können
vielleicht können sie mir helfen heute
ich habe mich total gewundert dass so
eine entscheidung selbst wenn es nachts
ist überhaupt zustande kommt wenn man
dann nicht weiß nicht mal ansatzweise
weiß wie ihm die umzusetzen es können
sie das erklären ist das völlig normal
im politischen berlin dass man was
beschließt und dann in den nächsten
tagen bei so einer wichtigen
entscheidungen die wirklich jeder jeden
alltag betrifft von allen deutschen dann
mal so ganz in ruhe cook geht das
überhaupt wie können wir das machen ja
es sollte nicht normal sein das ist ja
genau das was ich mit der methodik malt
also ist auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so
wichtig wäre der cdu erst sache
verantwortung übernehmen das
kernversprechen der cdu in ihrem markt
ende auch immer dass sie dieses lang
ordentlich regieren und den eindruck hat
man eben in den letzten wochen und
monaten nicht und da sagen
bürger genauso wie als positiv
demokratischer oppositionsparlamentarier
er meine erwartung für die nächsten
sechs monate und der erste schluss
daraus muss doch sein dass diese
methodik an eine grenze ist das haben
wir doch wie unterbränd glas rallye
mittags trifft man sich nicht früh
morgens sondern mittags wird angelegt
bis spät in die nacht
es gibt plötzlich überraschende
vorschläge die keiner vorher wegen oder
diskutieren könnte es wurde sich
geweigert vorher regierungserklärung
abzugeben
meistens wird überhaupt nicht im
parlament diskutieren und wenn dann
immer hinterher
das heißt dann kommen überraschende
vorschläge ja und die sind dann nicht
ausreichend bewogen worden sondern werde
irgendwie gruppendynamisch viele gute
lösung gehalten und halten dann am
nächsten tageslicht dieser überprüfung
nicht mehr stand und das meine ich mit
der regierungs methodik das klappt nicht
mehr
und das müssen sie jetzt verändern und
meine lösung wäre als erstes das tun was
richtig ist nämlich solche fragen auch
im parlament zu diskutieren und zwar
vorher
man kann so ein vorschlag diesem
realitäts check in reality check den er
offenbar nicht überlebt hat dann vorher
überleben oder eben nicht überleben in
dem fall hätte er ist ganz offenkundig
nicht überlegt wie kann das sein einer
klaus was ist ihre einschätzung dazu was
ist ihre erklärung dazu dass man zwei
feiertage sozusagen zwei zusätzliche
beschließt und dann plötzlich merkt die
ganzen detailfragen die kriegen wir
überhaupt nicht umgesetzt
ich muss ehrlich gesagt haben macht mich
auch als korrespondentin fassungslos
dass man das nicht hin könnt also eben
man weiß ja auch gar nicht was man
eigentlich jetzt daraus schlussfolgern
soll also ganz offensichtlich klingt es
ja klingt das ja die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nicht hin
man kann jetzt natürlich sagen ja gut im
parlament hätten sie es bestimmt besser
hingekriegt dann summe aber wieder dabei
hätte hätte fahrradkette
mein eindruck ist es bleibt jetzt nichts
anderes übrig als quasi das heft des
handelns selber in die hand zu nehmen
als auch ganz einfach als bürger in dem
man sich überlegt ist es jetzt sinnvoll
nach mallorca zu fliegen oder ist es
nicht
sinnvoll es nervt doch auch viele dass
sie ständig dinge vorgeschrieben
bekommen die sie dann eben am nächsten
tag befolgen müssen nun am übernächsten
tag wieder an aber aber sie sagen keine
regeln mehr also ab jetzt am besten
keine regeln mehr wir können es in jedem
fall besser wessi regierung überlassen
folgendermaßen ein sehr fatalistischer
ansatz zu sagen okay wenn sie da oben
nicht mehr hinkriegen dann müssen wir
selber hinkriegen aber es hat ja zum
beispiel bei der impfstoffentwicklung
auch gut funktioniert also ich meine ich
dass ich sie und jetzt kriegen aber wo
bürger sondern mehr ja- oder auch die
app der korona app funktioniert nicht
aber es gibt ja eine initiative von
künstlern die es auf eigene faust
probiert haben also ich will auch nicht
die hoffnung aufgegeben und hier nur
alles schwarz malen und und sagen die
welt geht unter wir schaffen es nicht
also es gibt initiativen auch auf ganz
hyper lokaler ebene rostock macht es vor
typen gemacht aber das ist ja also béla
anda hat schon gesagt eine erosion der
macht und anna klaus sagt jetzt auch als
bürgerin nicht nur als spiegel
korrespondent in das funktioniert
einfach nicht mehr grundsätzlich sollte
man das lieber den bürgern überlassen
als dieser regierung haben sie das in
der union überhaupt schon verstanden was
diese letzten stunden mit dem vertrauen
in sie in die regierung gemacht haben
ich glaube dass er das vertrauen in die
regierung dass sie auf die bürger hört
auch gestärkt und bw zu tut dass er der
bessere virologe ist und besser
abschätzen kann wie das funktioniert den
zoll ich meinen respekt ich würde mir
nicht zutrauen
aber was ich mir wünschen würde ist dass
wir den kreis derjenigen die wir als
experten für die politische vorbereitung
einbinden weiten weil was nicht
passieren darf ist dass der virus und
die pandemie sondern depression für ein
ganzes land wird das bedeutet im
umkehrschluss dass wir auch hergehen und
sagen okay
wie kriegen wir den bürgern wieder was
zu wie binden wir sie einen ich habe
vorhin vom tina prinzip gesprochen dass
wir ihnen sagen okay die test kapazität
müssen gesteigert werden es ist ein
rennen zwischen das wissen wir da hängt
ja gar nicht eine idee
da hängt sie an der umsetzung nein die
entscheidung die entscheidung ist dass
die bürger die komplexität dieser vielen
unterschieden regeln die alle
ministerpräsidenten beschlossen haben
nicht mehr verstehen und deswegen müssen
uns reduzieren auch ganz wenige aber
dafür nachvollziehbare regeln und ich
glaube da sind alle gefordert und wer
jetzt so tut das seine alleinige
initiative der bundesregierung der macht
sich einen sehr schlanken fuß und ich
finde es beachtlich dass kann man gerne
machen aber ich bin einmal festhalten
alle politischen parteien sitzen in
dieser ministerpräsidenten kommen verrät
das macht ja mit dem entsperrt was mache
ich dann noch schlimmer
ja aber deswegen glaube ich halt dass
wir nicht so tun sollten dass wenn
jemand einen fehler eingesteht dass das
gleich ein zeichen von erosion der
schwäche ist das gegenteil ist der fall
das man eben auch gewillt das sind und
ein mini anzuerkennen denn dass man
offen sich auch noch falsch liegen kann
und wenn sie jetzt wieder
bewertungsmaßstab ist dann wird man auch
zu diesem plan kommen weil der nächste
das nächste eingeständnis ist dass man
sich jetzt quasi alle drei wochen immer
von verordnung zur verordnung geangelt
hat aber darüber den blick verloren hat
was die einfachen klaren
nachvollziehbaren bürgers aber der punkt
ist ja nicht dass die bürger sehen hier
hat sich die korona lage verändert und
da muss ab und zu mal was angepasst
werden ich glaube dafür ist tatsächlich
das verständnis da das haben auch alle
umfragen in den vergangenen jahr gezeigt
dass man da da musste man so viel
flexibilität beweisen als bürger und hat
wahnsinnig viel verständnis auch für
anpassungen seitens der regierung
aufgebracht aber man hat eben kein
verständnis mehr
dass das impfen so schlecht organisiert
ist wie in kaum einem anderen
europäischen land das das testen
furchtbar schlecht organisiert ist und
dass man es nicht mehr schafft in
deutschland zwei feiertage und zu
organisieren mit diesem vorlauf für
andere kämpfen beim impfen kann ich kann
ihnen recht geben dass wir das
verbessern müssen aber zu weit oder auch
jede fünfte spritze in europa ist in
einem deutschen arm gegangen weil sie so
viel platz dabei aber genau das ist ja
fügt sie ich glaube dieses schönreden
verbessert gerade gar nichts sie haben
ja ich glaube dass das die die bürger er
wieder auf die palme bringt er an dass
man in deutschland nicht zwei feiertage
organisieren kann in der kürze das ist
doch eigentlich auch ein desaster lässt
sich das wirklich nicht machen
naja es fängt schon damit an wenn der
bundesinnenminister am nächsten morgen
aufsteht und sagt nicht jetzt zu sich
oder zu denen mit denen er da spricht in
der küche sondern tatsächlich den medien
dieses landes ich war gar nicht
informiert
also wenn jemand die logistik
organisieren muss das ist doch
bundesinnenminister
verteidigungsministerium ich gelernt
habe auch und daneben der
verkehrsminister und dann gehört es auch
dazu dass wenn man eine solche lage hat
diese leute zu ziehen und sie fragt um
ihre expertise
das ist politisches handwerk nun darf
ich jetzt angela merkel nicht vor dass
sie ihr handwerk nicht beherrscht aber
eben genau jetzt sind sie gar nicht ich
jetzt bin ich aber hoffentlich wieder da
nicht ihr handwerk berg aber es ist
trotzdem so dass man sich sehr wundern
warum sind diese dinge dann nicht
eingehalten worden und noch einmal die
das ansteigende inzidenz zahlen bei der
kern der begründung zusammenhänge die
wir in den letzten sechs sieben acht
monaten gehört haben diese zahlen
steigen weiter ich frage mich wie will
man darauf reagieren was er druckt
gesagt ist ein bisschen die neue linie
die wir hören nämlich dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger selber mehr tun
soll dass wir diese ins ident sind
vielleicht nicht als einziges kriterium
wahrnehmen soll
das ist eine völlige abkehr von dem was
uns bisher erzählt bauen wird und ich
frage mich wirklich auch als bürger wo
ist jetzt die gewissheiten uns immer
gesagt worden ist das dass er wert ist
dass wir uns orientieren
und jetzt geht das nicht mehr locker und
machen keinen sinn mehr da mich immer
gespannt was passiert wenn die zahlen so
anwachsen wie angela merkel ist ja
vorher sagt christian drosten und wie
auch immer wir waren eben noch bei der
frage wie kommen solche entscheidungen
überhaupt zustande die sich dann im
alltag nicht umsetzen lassen das cdu
urgestein wolfgang bosbach hat heute
hier bei bild diese erklärung gehabt
wenn nur menschen beschlüsse fassen die
dienstwagen haben und getönte scheiben
und dann die lebenswirklichkeit nicht
mehr so wahrnehmen
dann kann es passieren dass man zu der
berühmten formel
heft jetzt beschließen wir erst einmal
und dann gucken wir mal weiter
also wolfgang bosbach fordert johannes
vogel
er fordert raus aus den dienstwagen wenn
die beschlüsse nur von menschen gefasst
werden die die ganze zeit hinterher
getönten scheiben sitzen dann kommt
sowas bei raus ist das eine erklärung
ich auch selber ein und ich habe keinen
dienstwagen aber ich bin trotzdem so
ehrlich sagen dass die zukunft als
erklärung
das glaube ich nicht dass das das
kernproblem ist so eingängig ist auch
sein mag sein ich glaube das kernproblem
ist auch der falsche fokus also womit
beschäftigt sich diese im pkw ist gar
noch mal wiederholen warum der modus in
meinen augen zum falter gewohnt
beschäftigt sie mister
präsidentenkonferenz mit micro
management welcher supermarkt wie genau
sich am ostersamstag verhalten soll
das ist doch nicht richtig und
gleichzeitig sagen uns auch
regierungsvertreter
aber man muss von herrn voigt gehört
vertreter der regierungsparteien
das ist und es tue ihm vergeben muss ja
genau darauf wird sich aber ja nicht
konzentriert also seit januar liegen
vorschläge auf dem tisch wie das impfen
auch eine in beschleunigt werden könnte
wir sehen an anderen ländern den usa zum
beispiel eindrucksvoll dass man auch
eine laufende impfkampagne auch im
letzten sommer mit der bestellung
verbrachte beschleunigen kann
und seitdem werden habe ich nicht den
eindruck und ich glaube keiner kann er
gesehen habe dass wirklich alle register
gezogen werden dass zu einer nationalen
kraftanstrengung zu machen
der impf gipfel war eine reine sind
kleine verteilungsdiskussion und bei der
entscheidenden mpk geht's stunden lang
um andere fragen nämlich um kleinteilige
regelung von öffnungszeiten aus rast saß
das ist doch eine focus problem und ich
glaube in krisen ist focus sehr sehr
wichtig für management sie haben das
herz mit dem dienstwagen also etwas zu
plump abgetan heran da kennen sie
trotzdem als früherer regierungssprecher
von gerhard schröder dieses gefühl wenn
man länger im kanzleramt ist dass es
dann umso schwerer fällt den kontakt
nach außen zu halten dass es halt
schwerer fällt noch genau zu lauschen
was draußen los ist und man den alltag
etwas verliert nein das glaube ich nicht
auch wenn das natürlich sehr sehr
abgeschottet räume sind aber jetzt
schritte schützen sich davon dass ich
selbst sehr viel zu fuß gegangen ist und
dass man immer ein direktes feedback
bekommen hat auch gerade
einen politischen entscheidungen
angekommen sind da gab es natürlich
jeder jubel ganz im gegenteil
aber es gab ein ehrliches feedback und
ich glaube auch dass angela merkel auch
nicht abgehoben ist und dass sie sich da
wolfgang bosbach wirklich auch mit
diesen sehr plakativen äußerungen zu
einfach macht außerdem gibt es umfragen
die sagen einem jahr wie es aussieht und
das relativ gut auch darlegen nein das
ist so einfach ihr geht es um
politisches handwerk um das durchsetzt
und das exekutieren von maßnahmen und
das nachhalten von maßnahmen und das ist
etwas was wir so schafft beim wissen von
klaus wissen sie eigentlich was jetzt zu
ostern gilt mit dem einkaufen
ich mache eines ich schau bevor ich die
haustür verlass auf meine ft2 maske in
der linken hosentasche ist und noch eine
zweite e p2 maske in meiner tasche ist
und wenn ich weiß ich treffe mich mit
anderen leuten dann mache ich noch ein
selbst tester frau und ich teste auch
mein sohn selber bevor er sich mit
seinen großeltern zb trifft also und
dann habe ich den eindruck dass ich mich
richtig verlasse aber ich habe auch
jetzt überlegt an russland darf ich
jetzt eigentlich überhaupt mit meinem
mann mit meinem sohn mich mit den
großeltern treffen und ich kann schon
ehrlicherweise jeden verstehen der der
sagt ja schwamm drüber
ich mache jetzt einfach aber so
vernünftig muss man schon sein zu sagen
okay also der mallorca urlaub muss jetzt
vielleicht nicht wirklich sagen mich in
flieger kein hocken mit 200 leuten das
sagt einem doch eigentlich der
menschenverstand dass das gerade keinen
sinn macht béla anda hat ja gerade die
zahlen zitiert da stimmt und stimmt es
war halt aber erlaubte aber schwamm
drüber tatsächlich eine wiese auch nicht
immer darauf warten was die politik an
sagt irgendwann kann man doch auch
selber denken und und das vermisse ich
auch manchmal dass einem die regierung
zutraut selber zu denken ich habe das
gefühl uns bürgern wird so ein
permanentes misstrauensvotum
ausgesprochen so wenn wir nicht
entlocken verhängen dann rennen
heraus und an und sitzen nackt am strand
von mallorca also klares machen ein paar
und den innendienst gelungen ist heißt
gegönnt aber viele sind doch vernünftig
und wissen doch wie man sich verhält
pandemie um waschen sie auch die hände
regelmäßig erfolgte ich habe gerade
gefragt und die kanzlerin selbst hat ja
ja heute auch sich entschuldigt für die
verunsicherung die dadurch entstanden
ist wissen sie selbst was jetzt
eigentlich gilt sagt einzelhandel über
ostern und vor ostern hätte erste mal
weiß ich dass angela merkel ihre
einkäufe ja selber tätigt also insofern
dürfte sie dann ziemlich genau wissen
was das für auswirkungen hat für die
leute und das zweite ist das natürlich
mit der lockerung den gründonnerstag
angeht und auch den ostersamstag man im
prinzip wieder in den supermarkt nein
kann für mich entscheiden dass die leute
nicht verstehen man kann in den
supermarkt gehen und wird fast alles
einkaufen mittlerweile aber der
einzelhandel muss zu bleiben und genau
diese inkonsistenzen müssen wir der
nächsten mpk beseitigt werden das ist
der entscheidende punkt da setzen sie
auf die mpk na ja es sind alle
bundesländer die unterschiedliche
incidents level haben ich will das auch
sagen er an das recht in der ersten
phase ging es natürlich um incidents
level aber mittlerweile haben währen der
impfquote in deutschland von über zehn
prozent das heißt die hochrisikogruppe
zu großteil schon in lektion bekommen es
könnten mehr sein deswegen muss es auch
ein exportstopp geben von astrazeneca
innerhalb der eu gibt solche sachen wie
in italien nicht passieren dass da
einfach 29 millionen geortet werden
es muss darum gehen dass auch
betriebsärzte und hausärzte eingesetzt
werden kämpfen damit das beschleunigt
wird 24 stunden am besten zieht man dann
eben auch noch die siebte im spritze aus
dem biontech impfstoff mit zusätzlich
raus obwohl 06 legitim sind aber sieben
portioniert und dann hat man eben schon
eine beschleunigung das wird am 15 das
beschleunigen und deswegen kann ich
einfach nur sagen die pragmatischen
lösung mit gesundem menschenverstand
darum geht es jetzt aber was mich
irritiert hat gerade noch machen ihnen
erfolg dass sie sagen müsste die nächste
mpk weil bei allen unterschieden hier in
der runde wir haben ja schon eigentlich
versammelt festgestellt dass dieses
forum bisher nicht besonders gut
funktioniert hat und jetzt sagen wir
alle schauen wir auf die nächste mpk was
die beschließt ja vielleicht sollten wir
einfach meine gesetzeslage in deutsch
in unseren schauen mehr feststellen dass
die infektions schutzgesetz ist
natürlich in überwiegend exekutives
handeln ist und da sind die
landesregierung genauso gefragt wie die
bundesregierung darf sich keiner
wegducken und da soll ich damit seinen
besten vorschlägen an start gehen und da
gebe ich kollegen kugel durchaus recht
es macht auch sinn die parlamente mit
einzubinden um da auch quasi den breiten
reality check mitzumachen und es ist
logisch auch dass wir eine breitere
berücksichtigung auch von experten
brauchen also es ist vielleicht auch
manchmal der ein oder andere experte
müde geworden und deswegen behandelt
weitere debatte die lohnt sich schon
aber am ende muss es eben auch durch
eine landesregierung umgesetzt werden
und dafür braucht es dann letztlich auch
die mpk herr vogel kurze antwort zum
schluss dass wir ja frustrierend wenn
wir alle miteinander feststellen und so
habe ich die letzten wochen und monaten
ehrlich gesagt insgesamt erlebt was
funktioniert und was funktioniert nicht
und bei dem was funktioniert nicht
analysieren wir das ganz scharf aber
ändern am ende doch nichts also jetzt
ganz genau so bei der mpk wir sind uns
im grunde einig das forum klappt nicht
richtig und trotzdem werden da aber die
nächsten entscheidungen oder beschlüsse
fallen sollen es würden nicht
frustrierend dass ich heute die
kanzlerin im bundestag erlebt die ja da
auch ihre entschuldigung noch mal
vorgetragen hat und dass die
kursänderung und das erläutert hat und
da hat sie auch die frage wie haben sie
ja kritisch dazu gefragt ist dieses
ganze mpk format nicht so wie sie es im
moment auch setzt auch teil des problems
sollte sich sagt ja erst müsste man sich
anschauen
also ich hoffe schon dass das näher ist
als lippenbekenntnis war sonst hat er
auch die verantwortung weiter
durch dieses format entscheidungen
getroffen werden und dieses hinnehmen
dass wir nicht zufrieden sind in der
lage am bildnissen machen das wirklich
beim impfen das müssen wir überwinden
also da müssen da raus kommen aus dem
modus analysiert haben müssen wissen
dass testen
eine lösung ist stärker mit dem virus
leben zu können wir brauchen jetzt die
konkreten modelle dass das vor ort dann
dinge ermöglicht die vorher nicht
möglich waren
wir wissen dass impfen der einzigen weg
aus der krise so will ebenso
schulterzucken in das andere
immer mehr andere länder uns vormachen
wie man eben keinen beschleunigen kann
aus dem modus müssen bereits dann müssen
wir das tun frau clara dialog bei dem
dialog des heutigen tages zu bleiben das
müsse
wir uns anschauen herr vogel ja anschaut
reicht nicht mehr
also davon sind war das war vor monaten
müssen wir uns anschauen frau klaus wäre
wer führt denn eigentlich da jetzt in
der ministerpräsidenten runde mit der
kanzlerin wäre gibt einen moment den ton
an was würden sie sagen also ja herr
müller und herr söder haben ja ein
deutliche vorteile weil sie mit frau
merkel zusammen in einem raum sitzen in
der eine ist eben vorsitzender der mpk
der andere stellvertreter man hat ja
mittlerweile hat man ja als journalist
fast so live-schalten irgendwie mit über
über verschiedene kanäle mit in dieser
mpk und da merkte man schon als diese
dreistündige pizza pause lief wer gerade
das sagen hat und wer nicht also wer das
sagen hat man nämlich nicht im bild und
dass das war markus söder merkel müller
und armin laschet die ganze zeit
nebenher akten gezeichnet
also ja eher andere ganz kurz was ist
ihr eindruck wer da den ton angibt
ich bleibe dabei die macht wird sich
verlagern auf armin laschet und auch als
neuer cdu als nicht mehr neu aber
relativ neue cdu-vorsitzender
kanzlerkandidat und als vorsitzender des
mit bayern und niedersachsen mächtigsten
bundeslandes nordrhein westfalen und auf
markus söder an den beiden führt kein
weg vorbei aber auch dass malu dreyer
wenn man mal die spd nimmt eine größere
rolle spielt und aber bei den beiden
unions weiß dann wird die macht
tatsächlich zusammenlaufen
wir haben sie uns auch zum schluss herr
folgt wie ist es innerhalb der union
führt frau merkel noch in dieser gruppe
in dieser runde
ich glaube dass armin laschet dass
markus söder und angela merkel zusammen
führen und das ist auch gut so weil alle
anderen 23 sich wegducken und deswegen
ist es gut wenn die 30 mit andere rad
schlagen das ist eine total
diplomatische antwort funktioniert aber
nicht weil bei unterschiedlichen meinen
bei drei menschen ist man nie einer
meinung muss am ende einer sein der
entscheidet das war bisher die kanzlerin
wer ist es jetzt ist sie es noch oder
nicht mehr
ich glaube das ist nie eine person ist
die entscheidet ich glaube das haben wir
die letzten endes ja auch gesehen und
insofern glaube ich glaube schon dass
entschieden wird aber ich glaube das ist
auch darauf ankommen wird wer die
besseren argumente hat und es wird
derjenige der western argumente an der
in der nächsten mbk mit dem klaren plan
aufschlägt wie deutschland da jetzt
beschleunigt das ist ganz danke herzlich
für die diskussion hier mario voigt béla
anda johannes vogel und anna klaus in
allen schönen guten abend noch ganz
schön an länder ja das waren die
richtigen fragen hier an diesem so
bewegenden und bewegten politischen tag
an am abend nach dem ja so wortreich
ihrem möglicherweise schwerwiegendsten
größten fehler eingestand heute
vormittag völlig überraschend in berlin
als sie die oster ruhe die sie gerade
erst vor ein paar tagen mit dem
ministerpräsidenten beschlossen hatte
dann wieder zu rücknahmen und ihr genau
das nämlich diese oster ruhe eine ganze
menge ärger eingebracht hat so weit bis
morgen
[Musik]